As we define our goals and Key Performance
Indicators, or KPIs, for whatever business
or personal case, we need to make sure we’re
actually creating objectives that matter. Goals,
objectives, and KPIs are tools. They have a use.
They need to be designed and used with intention,
and a best practice of defining goals
and KPIs is using the SMART criteria.
In this video, we’ll define the SMART
criteria with relatable examples and
provide some best practice guidelines
for making your own SMART goals.
What are SMART goals?
SMART goals are ones that set objectives and KPIs
in a precise and easy to communicate way. First
described in print 1981 by author George T. Doran
and later expanded by Professor Robert S.
Ruben, SMART is an acronym that stands for:
• Specific
• Measurable
• Achievable
• Realistic
• Time-bound
SMART states that clear, attainable,
strategic goals are the most effective way
to create concrete milestones and metrics.
Instead of a general goal like “increase
sales,” we might consider a SMART goal like
“increase February’s year-over-year premium
subscription sales in California by 4%.”
SMART goals are the individual steps of a
well-considered strategy to achieving larger
objectives. If you were running a marathon
or climbing a mountain, SMART goals would
be the mile markers along the way, letting you
know where you are and how well you’re doing.
It isn’t just about getting to the end,
but rather what steps to take to get there.
SMART KPIs are what SMART goals use as the
accountable measurements, with a start and end.
Specific
Being clear about your goals and
expectations is the first step to reaching them.
When goals are too wide or vague, they are easy to
miss. If the definition is too broad, they become
harder to measure and also harder to achieve.
Being too vague allows for a lot
of error and misunderstanding.
It’s like climbing a mountain not knowing how
long the path is, how long it’s supposed to take,
what the conditions are, or even
what to wear while doing it.
With specific goals, you can see a path
form from start to finish. Specific KPIs
define the path even further with benchmarks,
ensuring everyone knows exactly where you are.
When you create your SMART goal,
try to answer questions like:
• What are the concrete steps in our plan?
• Who is necessary to make it happen?
• Where will our efforts take place?
• Why is this valuable to our long-term strategy?
• How do we prioritize this
goal compared to other goals?
Example of a Specific SMART goal: If Superman
is trying to “save the world,” then he’s
going to be more specific by narrowing the
objective to “prevent Lex Luthor’s plan.”
This helps Superman be a lot more focused in
his goals and helps him prioritize stopping
a supervillain over saving the endangered
ivory-billed woodpecker from extinction.
Measurable
If you can’t measure something,
you can’t tell if you’re performing well or if
you’re off track and need to course-correct.
In addition to being specific in your goals,
you need to be able to quantify your data
or indicate where you are progressing
towards your goal. Setting measurable
goals and criteria also lets everyone involved
evaluate their performance and stay on track.
When you create your SMART goal,
try to answer questions like:
• What data do we need?
• Where will our data live
and how will we access it?
• Is our data
reliable and verifiable?
• What are reasonable milestones?
• How much is enough and how much is not enough?
• How will we know we’ve accomplished our goal?
Example of a Measurable SMART goal: If your
goal is to climb a mountain in a day, then you’d
likely do some research and plan out how many
miles to hike per hour and track your progress.
You would then measure your distance
and time according to your goal.
This is a much SMARTer plan than instead
looking up to the top of the mountain in
the afternoon and just starting to
walk, hoping to the top by sundown.
Achievable
It’s important to look
at your end objectives and plan out goals that are
within realistic capabilities. It’s also important
not to get too carried away and use far-fetched
or unreachable goals as motivators, constantly
chasing an impossibly lofty goal. Allow yourself,
and your stakeholders, to feel motivated by the
satisfaction of achievement and real progress.
When setting goals, be ambitious and push for
success, but also understand internal and external
limits. Achievement needs to be sustainable.
When you create your SMART goal,
try to answer questions like:
• What are the necessary
steps to achieve this goal?
• How much direct control do we
have over achieving this goal?
• Is this goal realistic
compared to previous performance?
• What is the precedent?
• Why do we think this goal is achievable?
• What external (and internal) factors
might prevent us from achieving this goal?
Example of an Achievable SMART goal:
Search-and-rescue dogs’ have a singular purpose
to find survivors of disasters like earthquakes
or terrorism attacks. In order to keep the dogs
motivated in especially fatal disaster areas, dog
handlers will sometimes hide “fake” survivors for
the dogs to rescue so the dogs will be motivated
to continue their hard work. The gratification
of achievement empowers and sustains the
continued good behavior of achievement.
Realistic (and Relevant)
Similar to the achievable criteria above,
goals also need to be realistic and relevant.
Setting goals that are completely out of reach
won’t make your team strive to reach harder,
but at the same time setting goals that
are too easy won’t make your team better.
It’s also important to make sure your goals are
relevant to your goals or business objectives
over time. KPIs need to measure your business
goals over short-term and long-term strategies
and it’s ok to adjust criteria as time passes.
What works now won’t always work the same later,
and it’s important to identify when business needs
change. Stay aware of your long-term goals, but
don’t be afraid to readjust the short-term tactics
that will help achieve those long-term plans.
When you create your SMART goal,
try to answer questions like:
• Why is this the goal now?
• Why wasn’t this the goal in the past?
• Who are the right people to pursue this goal?
• How will this goal advance a long-term strategy?
• What is the anticipated
return on investment (ROI)?
• What would it mean if we
failed to reach this goal?
Example of a Realistic SMART goal: If your
ultimate goal is to climb Mount Everest but
you’ve never climbed a whole mountain before, it
would be unrealistic to head straight to Everest.
The criteria suggested above indicate that you
should first be asking yourself why you should be
trying to hike Mount Everest at all, if you're
the right person to be hiking Mount Everest,
and what it would mean if you didn't make
it to the top. If you decided to proceed,
you then would need to plot out a
realistic training schedule for the feat.
Time-bound
The final letter of
SMART is often overlooked, but it’s incredibly
important to have a time-frame for your goals.
A time-bound goal can consist of either start and
end-points or a collection of timed parameters or
milestones. You may have a deadline to reach
certain objectives in order to stay on track.
Or you may want to track metrics across
a period of time, whether it’s daily,
monthly, or quarterly. Whatever you choose,
plan ahead of time to make sure your KPIs
can be measured as time passes in order for
you to reach your goals in a timely manner.
When you create your SMART goal,
try to answer questions like:
• Is this achievable in the given time frame?
• What is the longest and shortest
possible time to achieve this goal?
• What potential blockers or time-related
factors could delay progress?
• What have we accomplished
in similar time frames in the past?
• When and how will we check for progress?
• What do we do if we’re
off-track halfway through?
• Are there any times where progress
might naturally slow down or speed up?
Example of a Time-bound SMART goal: For a simple
health example, consider everyone’s favorite New
Year’s Resolution: “I’m going to go to the gym
more.” A SMART fitness goal might include defining
exactly how often and for how long we’ll go
to the gym. Instead of a very general goal,
you might resolve to go to the gym three days a
week for one hour each day, for the next month.
Or, if you wanted to lose weight, you might
make a time-bound fitness goal like this:
“I’m going to lose 10 pounds
over the next three months.”
You might then decide on check-in milestones every
two weeks to stay on track. Of course, it would be
up to the rest of the SMART criteria to determine
other details about the how of this goal.